- Somebody asked me last week,
"You usually have themes
for these conferences."
Last year was realizing your potential.
The year before that
we had a birthday party
for the Americans with
Disabilities Act, the ADA.
This year it's A to Z.
Tomorrow there's more about
autism and spectrum disorders.
Now we start the Z part,
which is a panel on Zika virus,
and many or most of the
disabilities associated
with Zika infection have
to do with disabilities.
Since our planning and advisory committee,
and thank you to all the planning
and advisory committee
members who are here,
recommended on behalf
of the regional centers
and parents and families
that there's a lot of concern
about Zika and its various considerations.
So we have gotten together a panel
of experts and we're starting where,
I guess we should start with obstetrics.
We are pleased to have our
first member of the panel,
Dr. Kirsten Salmeen, who's
an Assistant Professor
of Obstetrics, Gynecology
and Reproductive Sciences
at the Division of
Maternal-Fetal Medicine at UCSF.
Kirsten, thank you for joining us.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much for the opportunity
to talk with you all today.
It's a real honor to be here.
I have no financial disclosures to make.
The three take-home points that I'm hoping
to leave you all with in
the next 20 minutes or so
are seen up on the screen there.
The first is that we know with the caveat
that we never really know
anything completely in medicine,
be we know that prenatal
Zika virus exposure
causes fetal injury.
We know that there are
considerable challenges
in prenatal testing and diagnosis,
so identifying an impact
on a fetus prenatally
is quite challenging.
I'm going to challenge
everybody who interacts
with pregnant patients or
future pregnant patients
that our obligations for these patients
are to advise, screen and test, support,
and advocate about the impacts
of Zika virus in pregnancy.
A very brief word on background,
and you'll hear more about
this from the other speakers,
but just to get everybody
oriented to Zika.
If you are like me, a year and a half ago
you had never heard of the Zika virus.
In Brazil in fall of 2015
lots of health workers
in Northeast Brazil started to notice
increased rates of
microcephaly in newborns,
which started to get people thinking about
what the causes could
be and working backwards
people started to notice
that there was this outbreak
of Zika virus in May of 2015.
Zika virus isn't new.
It was first identified
in 1947 in the Zika Forest
in Uganda, which is why
it's called the Zika virus.
The first human cases were in the 1950s.
Really, since the fall
of 2015 we sort of seen
Zika virus explode on the scene.
As of today, we have
Zika virus transmission
in the United States in
Texas and in Florida.
The Zika virus is a mosquito-borne virus.
It is in the Flavivirus family,
and it's similar to dengue, West Nile,
yellow fever, Japanese encephalitis.
This similarity is part of
why it can be challenging
to make a prenatal diagnosis.
The primary mode of
transmission is by mosquitoes.
Far and away the most
common form of transmission.
However, maternal to fetal
transmission is also an issue,
hence why I'm here.
Sexual transmission
has also been reported,
although is less of a concern.
Then there's also the theoretic concern
about transmission via blood transfusion,
laboratory exposures, and transplants,
although there have been
vanishingly few reported
cases transmitted in those fashions.
As of February 1, 2017
in the United States
the number of pregnant
women with laboratory
evidence of Zika virus infection,
in the States, it's around 1,400.
In U.S. Territories,
which primarily includes
Puerto Rico, which is the
biggest area, is about 3,000.
We've seen 38 liveborn
infants in the United States
with birth defects thought to
be attributed to Zika virus,
and five reported pregnancy losses,
although, of course, that's very hard
to track pregnancy loss.
Transitioning now to how we
know that prenatal Zika virus
really causes fetal injury.
When we think about how we know
that something harms a fetus,
in the business we sort of think about
these Shepard's Criteria.
These are seven criteria
that were outlined
first published in the 1990s,
but sort of evolved over time,
how we know something
has an impact on a fetus.
These criteria are what's required.
So first, a proven exposure to an agent
at a critical time during pregnancy.
Consistent findings in high
quality epidemiologic studies.
Careful delineation of a clinical case.
Rare environmental exposure associated
with a rare defect that allows
us to make that association.
Teratogenicity in an experimental model.
We like that, but it's not essential.
The association has to
make sense biologically.
Ideally there's proof in
an experimental system
that the agent acts in an unaltered state,
meaning that we actually see
the agent causes problems.
Starting with some
epidemiological evidence
that Zika virus causes fetal injury.
These are the earliest
reports out of Brazil
looking at rates of microcephaly
in their population.
This is sort of what
the baseline rates were,
and I'll talk about
this a little bit later,
but microcephaly isn't a new finding.
Many fetuses are affected by microcephaly,
but these were microcephaly
rates in Brazil.
Up until 2014 some were in the ballpark
of five to six per 100,000.
The first reports of autochthonous,
meaning spread by mosquitoes in that area,
not acquired from travel,
happened right around here
in the spring of 2015.
By the end of 2015 their rates
were around 100 per 100,000.
And actually were probably
closer to 250 per 100,000.
So really dramatic uptick in the numbers.
Even if this was just reporting bias,
it still is kind of too much to ignore.
Other epidemiological evidence
has come out since that time.
These are two papers that were published
in follow-up to that Zika
outbreak that happened
in French-Polynesia that demonstrated
significant increase in
rates of microcephaly
after Zika epidemics.
In that Cauchemez study,
the Zika-associated risk
of microcephaly was estimated
to be around 95 per 10,000
versus a baseline of two per 10,000.
The Besnard study demonstrated
a 14-fold increase
in congenital microcephaly,
and a 31-fold increase
in brainstem dysfunction.
So mounting epidemiologic evidence.
Moving on to the delineation
of clinical cases.
As this evidence started to come out,
and people started to
publish case reports,
these findings were what
were pretty consistently
associated with women who had been exposed
to Zika virus during pregnancy.
Microcephaly, cortical
brain malformations,
so abnormalities of the white matter.
Abnormalities of the posterior
fossa and cerebellum.
Ventriculomegaly, enlargement of those
fluid-filled spaces in the brain.
Intracranial calcifications.
Ophthalmologic abnormalities,
growth restriction, and fetal death.
I said I'd speak for a
moment about microcephaly.
I think it's important
to note that microcephaly
by itself is not a new diagnosis.
Strictly speaking it means small head,
but the real problem is
the underlying small brain
and abnormal brain structures
that result in this smallness.
Even still now in the United States
and countries that aren't
having a lot Zika problems,
the most common causes of microcephaly
are genetic abnormalities or differences,
infections like CMV is a very common cause
of microcephaly prenatally.
Exposures to things like
alcohol and substances.
It's defined as having a
newborn head circumference
greater than two standard
deviations below the mean.
And again, is associated
with small brain volume,
seizures, intellectual disabilities,
cognitive differences, motor disabilities,
and behavioral problems.
The exact cause of microcephaly probably
has more impact on the outcome
than the microcephaly itself.
The parts of the brain that are involved
are important for exactly what
the phenotypic appearance is.
But this entity by itself isn't new.
Continuing on with those
Shepard's Criteria,
the rare exposure rare effect.
We saw lots of clinical
evidence and continue to see
more clinical evidence
that fetuses and newborns
among mothers living in
or traveling to areas
where Zika virus was being transmitted
have been found to consistently
have these findings.
And probably most importantly,
Zika virus was isolated from tissue,
from pregnancy losses, amniotic fluid,
and newborn serum and urine,
as well as CNS tissues.
So that association of the
rare exposure rare effect
was pretty well established.
In more recent publications,
so this is from late 2016,
there was a couple of
more compelling cases
that really sealed the
deal in the association
of Zika and fetal injury.
This Franca study was a case
series that looked at 1,500
cases of reported microcephaly.
In other words, a delivering
clinician reported
that the newborn head
measurements were not normal.
And of those 1,500, 602 had
actual evidence of Zika virus.
A large number of those actually ended up
not being true microcephaly.
But there were 600 cases that
had evidence of Zika virus.
Those women who had evidence
of Zika virus exposure
had newborns with smaller
heads circumferences,
pretty considerably higher
first-week mortalities.
So 51 versus 14 per 1,000.
Many more women reporting
rashes during pregnancy,
so 60% versus about 20%.
And multiple brain abnormalities
despite normal head sizes.
I think this is the point that caught many
of our attention from
a prenatal perspective,
is that these children seemed
to have brain abnormalities
even with normal head measurements,
making it seem like prenatal diagnosis
got even more challenging.
This study by de Araujo and colleagues
was a case control study.
So looking at 32 cases of microcephaly,
and 62 controls with
normal head measurements.
Demonstrated an odds ratio
for Zika virus exposure
of about 55, with a
95% confidence interval
between 8.6 and infinity.
Before I read this study I
had never seen an infinite
top-end of a confidence interval.
Then in cases with brain abnormalities,
that odds ratio was
about 113, meaning there
is a very, very, very strong correlation
between Zika exposure and
these newborn abnormalities.
Just for reference,
the association between
smoking and lung cancer,
the odds ratio is somewhere
around five or six,
eight, 10 depending on
the study that you read.
So this was pretty compelling.
This is the final large cohort study,
looking at Zika positive versus
Zika negative infants and outcomes.
Looking at this total
adverse infant outcome,
which is a composite of
many of these things,
demonstrated that Zika positive women
had about a 42% risk of adverse outcomes,
versus about 5% of unexposed
or Zika negative women.
The biologic plausibility
is also very compelling.
We know that this exists
from other TORCH infections,
so that infectious diseases
can cause fetal injury
is not a new concept for us.
We also know that Zika virus
demonstrates neurotropism,
meaning the Zika virus is able to attack
and does preferentially attack cells
of the developing nervous system.
So those cells that are normal
when infected by Zika virus
become abnormal and we've seen this
is mouse and primate models.
Shepard's Criteria are really met,
and as a consequence we
can feel quite confident
that Zika virus really
does cause fetal injury.
Testing and diagnosis
is really challenging.
So moving on to that
second take-home point.
The clinical presentation of Zika virus
is really tricky about 20 to 40% of people
remember having symptoms.
So most are infected and don't recognize
that they have symptoms or
are totally asymptomatic.
It's a mild febrile illness.
The maculopapular rash
doesn't affect everybody
and can go relatively unnoticed.
It looks really similar to lots of other
arthopod-borne illnesses.
So in areas where dengue is common,
it looks a lot like dengue,
although less severe.
So it's easy to go unnoticed.
The recommended testing for pregnant women
is really complex.
Currently only IgM testing is available.
There is no IgG testing.
So keeping in mind that
IgG is able to tell us
longer term historic exposure versus IgM
which tells us this acute exposure.
So testing with IgM
has to be done, really,
within 12 weeks of exposure,
which necessitates knowing
when that exposure happened.
IgG testing is not available.
And there's a pretty
considerable overlap with the IgM
testing for dengue, chikungunya,
other similar arthopod-borne illnesses.
Women who have a positive
IgM test for Zika virus
have to have confirmatory testing,
which currently is only done by the CDC,
and takes quite some time to do.
PCR testing, or actual
testing for the virus,
is now available for urine and blood,
but does not stay positive indefinitely.
We're still really trying
to understand how long
it is able to stay positive
or definitely stays positive.
Amniocentesis, or taking
fluid from around the fetus,
and testing for Zika virus is an option.
But we really don't have a
great sense of false-positive
and false-negative rates.
False-positive is probably quite unlikely,
however a positive test in a mother,
or a positive test in a
fetus doesn't then guarantee
translation to an affected fetus.
So an infected mother and
fetus doesn't necessarily
mean that that child is
affected by the Zika virus
and we don't really know the conditions
under which that's the case.
There are a lot of complicated algorithms.
The CDC has done a good job
of keeping us up-to-date,
but presently what we recommend is that
symptomatic pregnant women
who have been exposed
get PCR testing up to two weeks
after their symptom onset.
Asymptomatic pregnant women
who have been exposed,
which means either traveling to an area
where Zika virus has been transmitted,
or having unexposed sex
with a person who's traveled
to an area where Zika
virus is transmitted,
are recommended to have anti-IgM testing
being two and 12 weeks after the last date
of possible exposure,
and then PCR testing within two weeks.
Women who have negative PCR,
but who have a positive IgM
have to have their blood sent to the CDC
for confirmatory testing.
So it's a process that
takes quite some time.
We do use ultrasound,
especially in very highly developed areas,
where we have lots of
access to ultrasound.
We do ultrasounds to monitor and evaluate.
We do serial ultrasounds over the course
of the third trimester to watch.
But again, only some Zika
virus-affected fetuses
have ultrasound findings.
Non-Zika virus affected fetuses
may have abnormal ultrasounds.
So we can't be certain with ultrasound
that what we're seeing is Zika-related.
We can't be certain that a fetus
that has a normal appearing
ultrasound wasn't affected by Zika virus.
Ultrasound findings can be quite subtle.
Microcephaly is a little bit
of a challenging diagnosis.
We suspect it when the
fetal head measurements
are less than two standard deviations
below the mean for gestational age.
We diagnosis it definitively
when the size is more
than four to five standard
deviations below the mean.
But fetal head measurements
are a little bit subjective.
They're very dependent
on maternal habitus.
How well we're able to see,
the position of the fetus.
So although we can be quite certain when
there's profound microcephaly,
it's hard to be certain when
there is a small degrade.
The other abnormalities there are variable
in terms of how easy they are to see.
Fetal Brain MRI is a tool
with great potential,
but is really only available
in very high-resourced places,
with a very sub-specialized care.
So it really isn't ubiquitously available.
We do here and a couple of other centers
in the United States and around the world.
But it's not particularly accessible.
Lastly the final point
here is that as health care
providers I think our role at this point
are to advise, screen and test,
support, and then advocate.
I think that we really should
be advising pregnant women
and those who are planning
a pregnancy to try
and avoid areas where Zika
virus is being transmitted.
If avoiding travel is not an option,
the recommendation is to use FDA-approved
mosquito repellents, protective clothing,
staying indoors when possible.
Condom use, if a partner
has traveled is recommended,
really for a pregnant women throughout
the entirety of her pregnancy.
We strongly suggest
contraception for those
who are not wanting to conceive,
which is a big problem
is some of the parts
of the world where Zika virus
is being transmitted really actively.
The current recommendation
is that women wait
at least eight weeks
after a potential exposure
to try and conceive.
Although there's a very,
very, very recent paper
in the New England Journal that suggests
that that may need to be
expanded a little bit longer.
Then for male partners, the recommendation
is to wait at least six
months before trying
to conceive because Zika
virus has been identified
in semen for up to six
months after exposure.
Yeah, that's a long time.
(group laughter)
That doesn't mean you can't
have sex for six months.
It just means you shouldn't
get pregnant for six months.
Screening and testing.
So screening for exposure,
and this is a big deal within
our prenatal populations.
It's interesting, Zika's not
really in the paper anymore.
It's not on TV, too many
other things on TV right now.
(group laughter)
So it's sort of fallen off the radar,
and patients are becoming a lot more
lackadaisical about travel.
So we really feel like it's our job to
continue to advise women
about avoiding travel
and unprotected sex.
Using those testing
algorithms and considering
an electronic health
record is what we've done
in our practice to trigger
questions about travel,
so we know who to screen.
From a support perspective,
I think we spend the
vast majority of our time
reassuring the worried well.
Those numbers in the beginning say there's
really still quite infrequent
cases in the United States,
but being thoughtful about
who we're counseling how.
For those women who are high
risk for fetal infections,
so women who test positive,
who have ultrasound findings,
providing patient-preference
centered counseling
is very, very important.
Talking about the lack of predictability,
of the impacts of Zika,
the potential for a
broad range of outcomes,
the challenges with knowing
how this looks in the longterm,
because this is still relatively new,
all need to factor into this discussion.
For those who are choosing
expectant management,
we recommend serial
ultrasounds, antenatal testing,
and providing resources,
counseling, and support.
This perhaps is an
audience that can tell me
a lot more about that than I can speak to.
For those families who make
the decision to consider
pregnancy termination providing
those support services
and options when appropriate.
Last but not least, I
think it's our obligation
to really advocate.
Advocating for vaccine development,
for vector control, for education,
for family planning, for
surveillance, for support.
We are sort of the people
who carry the torch
for trying to advocate for the patients
who are being affected by this.
I think we're obliged to advocate
from a policy perspective.
So advocating for the importance
of family planning services.
There's some evidence that up to half
of reproductive-aged women in Brazil
are at least trying to
avoid pregnancy right now
because of Zika virus.
But contraceptive services in
that area are really limited.
Vector control strategies,
then advocating for strategies
to really stay up-to-date.
This is changing very quickly
and staying up-to-speed
is really important.
To conclude my portion here, again,
prenatal Zika virus exposure
causes fetal injury.
We're nearly certain of that.
Prenatal testing and diagnosis
is really challenging
and I think our roles are
advising, testing and screening,
support and advocate.
I think that there's a bunch
that we still really don't know,
so we really don't know the
probability of an affected
fetus and an infected mother.
That's still, we really
need to learn a lot about.
We really don't know about
the long-term implications
for these children.
We don't know about ameliorating
or exacerbating factors.
It still seems unusual that this is mostly
in Northeast Brazil where the
most significant impacts are.
We really don't know the
kind of economic, social,
and other consequences.
So I think that's more to come.
So I'll wrap up with that and
pass on to my next panelist.
(group applause)
Thank you.